la Villa La Savana Marnes-la-Coquette ou
Johnny Hallyday a passé ces derniers
moments est en vente et son prix vient
d'être révélée c'est combien Laeticia
Hallyday a d'abord publié une annonce à
17,9 millions de dollars mais aucun
acheteur n'a été trouvé il a donc été
revu à la baisse à 10,5 millions d'euros
combien une surface habitable de 900 m²
sur un terrain d'environ un hectare elle
comprend une salle de cinéma privée une
suite parentale avec terrasse 5 chambres
de grande racine des dépendances et un
grand salon de 110 mètres carrés avec
une belle cheminée pour allumer le feu
on ne sait pas si la popularité de
Johnny Hallyday permettra de vendre
finalement la propriété mais si le prix
vous donne l'envie d'avoir envie vous
pouvez toujours les contacter dès
maintenant
avant de nous poser la question si
Laetitia telle raison de liquider
l'héritage de livre ça fait énormément
parler on va visiter ensemble à la
maison
immobilier donc nous arrivons voilà à
l'entrée la maison de Johnny avec un
magnifique une magnifique petite
parcelle de terrain
voilà la Villa elle est composée donc
voilà comme ceci vous voyez en deux
étages je crois qu'il y a des étages en
dessous c'est très beau comme ça
ça c'est derrière ce qu'on avait jamais
vu moi j'avais jamais vu ces photos là
toi tu vois je te jure
non plus de conneries
tu rentres là-bas
non non
c'est devant en fait tu le vois quand tu
arrives comme ça de la rue tu le vois tu
l'achèteras et puis tu nous feras pas
[Rires]
vous rentrez et vous tombez sur un
séjour de 110 mètres carrés de plein
pied de plain-pied ça veut dire qu'il y
a plein de pieds
regardez sur terrasse et jardin avec
parquet et cheminée pas mal
nous regarde
alors là c'est le salon voilà donc le
salon 2 vous voyez ou pas voilà avec un
peu clair le parquet est un peu clair
merci voilà et là et là ils ont mis un
fauteuil c'est pour le gars qui est
vraiment qui est puni c'est pour les
gars qui veulent regarder la télé tu vas
derrière tu nous emmerdes allez voilà tu
te tasse soit là tu te tais voilà donc
c'est pas un kiffe cette petite visite
[Rires]
c'est dans cette assiette que Johnny a
mangé un jour une tomate mozza
qui était son hordeur préféré voilà pour
ceux qui aiment bien les petites la
musique on va aller tout de suite
maintenant il y a 5 chambres on va aller
on n'allons pas tout de suite dans la
chambre parentale on finira par la
chambre parentale laissez-moi faire je
suis agent immobilier je sais comme un
paquet de Chalon d'accord donc d'abord
on va aller dans la chambre 2 si on
régit vous m'entendez vous me le dites
voilà la chambre 2 voilà la chambre 2
alors voilà c'est très sympa et il y a
une télé par contre là il fallait là par
contre là vous voyez là il y a le fil
qui pense qu'on va mettre une petite
baguette pour cacher le fil rien du tout
je suis un menu
je me suis mashado il peut venir il est
génial
c'est magnifique c'est juste tu vas vous
mettre une petite baguette ici et ça
c'est magnifique et la cheminée marche
par contre faut pas la mettre là parce
que sinon elle brûle le canapé
sinon voilà la cheminée marche et là
vous avez un canapé voilà et ils ont
choisi un camaïeu de bleu il y a des
poutres apparentes comme dans votre slip
et pour les filles
pour les petites fissures
c'est rien il y a eu un petit dégât des
eaux il y a de sa 12 ans mais tout a été
réalisé
c'est un petit coup de peinture d'accord
vous allez rafraîchir
vous allez voir dans le jeu
vous allez rafraîchir ouais donc voilà
donc voilà donc ça c'est la chambre il y
a une deuxième chambre regardez la
chambre 3 je voudrais voilà alors là
c'est la chambre de garçon par
excellence
c'est la chambre voilà ils ont mis un
petit bureau pour faire ses devoirs et
là vous voyez on a eu c'est très sympa
parce qu'ils ont mis comme des petits
stores
c'est un marchand de glace j'ai je me
rappelle les filles de Diony quand elles
étaient petites adoré ouvrir le stop
comme ça et faire qu'est-ce que je vous
sers et là ça a duré des heures tout le
monde rigoler la famille était heureuse
vous pouvez le garder ça c'est vraiment
alors ça tous les gens qui visitent me
disent ça ça je vais le garder ça ça met
une animation dans la maison donc voilà
ça c'est la chambre tout alors du coup
vous voyez qu'il y a toujours un canapé
au cas où voilà pour poser ses affaires
climatisé alors non fierté de la maison
est climatisé ça a été refait je peux
vous dire la climatisation et je peux
vous le dire on a chaud l'hiver et froid
en été alors là je peux vous le dire là
il y a pas de moustique BIM BIM les
moustiques on va voir maintenant la
chambre une autre chambre enfant qui se
trouve au dessus une chambre enfant
voilà c'est une salle de la salle de
jeux ça ça
permet aussi
il y a aussi un lit cabane
Johnny a écrit je te promets
c'est dans cette petite cabane que
Johnny il avait écrit voilà
il y a des têtes
donc c'est la vraie maison de Johnny
c'est incroyable regardez donc voilà
alors c'est un petit peu mansardé mais
c'est rien du tout exactement c'est un
ancien manoir c'est donc voilà Monsieur
rien
ça fait un petit plaisir
j'aimerais maintenant qu'on voit la
chambre de Johnny après vous allez voir
les surprises la chambre de Johnny la
chambre de Johnny s'il vous plaît là où
Johnny dormez voilà ah ouais ça va et
c'est sûr c'est sûr
et voilà c'était là voilà donc là voilà
ça c'est la chambre de Johnny alors avec
lui très épaisse la dernière fois je
suis allé pieds nus sur sa moquette j'ai
perdu mon pied
impossible de le retrouver
alors le lit a l'air dur et bah pour une
fois que vous serez quelque chose de dur
ça bouge c'est une avancé tu te trompes
c'est une avancée le lit il est après
regarde bien sûr c'est l'avancée que tu
crois que c'est dur exactement
de Johnny c'est le noir exactement
voilà donc ça c'est la chambre de Johnny
là on est dans la chambre de Johnny on
est vraiment plongé est-ce que Johnny
dormait à droite ou à gauche à votre
avis
la droite ou à gauche à droite qu'est-ce
qui vous fait dire ça les photos les
photos à droite et dormez à droite bien
sûr Bernard Montiel il dormait de ce
côté-là bien sûr et là il y avait
Laetitia exactement voilà vous vous êtes
trompés Johnny dormez là-bas pour avoir
un accès directement à la salle de bain
pour sortir direct leur foi exactement
exactement
et il y avait il y a deux grands
dressings les demandais s'ils sont
incroyables les dressings sont fous
vraiment c'est le dressing de Johnny il
incroyable toujours que tu as déjà vu le
dressing de Johnny oui ben sa maison
dans cette maison là moi j'ai vu celle
de la Lorada et j'ai vu Los Angeles
c'est incroyable
il est incroyable on a parlé ah bah
ouais mais alors et il y a une salle
regarder un petit peu spéciale regardez
une salle ce que Johnny adorait regarder
des films une salle de cinéma
il a une salle de cinéma et vous voyez
mal ça et apparemment voilà et il a et
il était venu en vélo en fait
il a laissé là après il a toujours
laissé de vélo là qui était un ancien
vélo ah ouais c'est beau ou pas
c'est presque un peu émouvant moi je
trouve énormément
c'est là que Johnny a regardé la Grande
Vadrouille
[Rires]
un petit peu en retrait et voilà il
mangeait
de Johnny merci bouge pas on visite la
la maison de Johnny si vous nous
rejoignez à 19h37 c'est incroyable
regardez là maintenant la salle de sport
de Johnny la salle
et en fait dès qu'il y avait une
nouvelle machine il a acheté donc en
fait il en parle et c'est ça plein de
toutes ces maisons il y avait une salle
comme ça incroyable c'est sûr
vous avez un truc comme ça vous une
salle de sport comme ça
est-ce que vous aimez le sport vous êtes
une très belle piscine également une
très belle piscine extérieure magnifique
alors voilà alors là alors ça c'est rien
à remplacer
non mais c'est vrai tu me donnes de la
pâte à fixe
alors voilà et et il y a un cours de
tennis un cours de tennis
voilà il faut faire la pour refaire un
petit voilà un gros voilà donc
aujourd'hui
donc Bernard Montiel on va revoir vous
allez avoir les photos de la photo de
Johnny la chambre tout ça derrière la
moitié vous avez donc des infos
je voulais dire c'est que cette maison
cette maison Johnny l'a jamais vraiment
aimé il a acheté c'est pas la ville la
plus chère
revenu c'est ça c'est vrai mais c'est
pas la ville la plus chère
c'est vrai voilà mon chéri
comme ça je te comme ça ce soir tu dises
pas une connerie
comme ça tu vas passer pour un con ça me
fait chier toi je te le dis voilà vous
avez raison
dans ce je voulais dire c'est que Johnny
il a acheté en 1999 4 millions 9 et en
2010 il y a eu un gros problème dans la
baraque c'est que son gardien s'était
bourré la gueule et comme il était assez
tendu euh le gardien est surtout ivre il
a commencé à tirer sur les gens qui
s'approchaient trop près de la propriété
et pourtant c'est un domaine déjà privé
déjà pour entrer il y a un portail vous
avez vu parce que vous êtes allé donc
c'est déjà tout un bordel
donc ça Johnny est quand même un homme
timide que tu étais un homme timide et
tu es très emmerdé par cette histoire
parce que ses voisins sont tous des gens
d'abord très importants qui soient
importants ou pas on tire pas sur les
voisins de toute façon il y avait les
murs du Qatar il y avait les lumières du
Qatar j'accélère pas trop loin il y
avait tout un tas de personnalités comme
ça et donc du coup il a il a mis en
vente en 2010 une première fois 26
million
de foot
alors ça c'est le ça c'est pour un alors
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle un non un
boudoir
investibule je sais pas
vous avez bien raison et là c'est là que
Johnny venait lorsqu'il venait près là
c'est après un concert voilà il venait
s'allonger ici et il posait ses bottes
juste là voilà ce niveau là et voilà il
posait ses santiags ici et là il était
bien il était en chaussettes et regardez
la balle le paysage il adoré cet arbre
cet arbre là qui est un séquoia
partenaire
voilà il faut regarder pendant des
heures
alors ça ça c'est l'entrée c'est
l'entrée c'est quand vous entrez dans la
maison c'est le box il reste ou pas ou
Johnny le jukebox il avait un truc
Johnny détesté
avoir ses chansons dans le jukebox il y
avait des chansons de tous les autres
artistes il avait dadju
non série il avait en bande organisé
il détestait quand quelqu'un mettez une
chanson de lui un jour il y a un ami à
lui qui a mis noir c'est noir je me
rappelle au Jukebox
et là c'est un déferlement de haine
et cette amie c'est Bernard Montiel
mais c'est un Obernai ça c'était c'était
l'entrée c'est l'entrée non mais je suis
pas allé dans cette maison d'accord ça
se sent c'est Bernard
et donc aujourd'hui autre info donc il a
il a acheté 4 millions 9 4 millions 999
il a essayé de la revendre en 2010 26
millions et 26 millions
et après suite à tous ces histoires et
problèmes avec le fils que Laetitia l'a
vendu elle avait affiché à 17 millions
17 millions et là non plus c'est pas
possible le vrai le vrai prix calme-toi
Laetitia va te défoncer frère non alors
justement alors je vais vous donner
parce que oui
mais frère si tu veux plus ne leur parle
le plus lui parler elle a combien elle a
annonce à combien à la maison
500 je vais attendre qu'elle tombe 5
je vais attendre qu'elle tombe à 500000
10500 10500 les 500 oubliés oui non
c'est la commission sur moi pour
l'agence
[Rires]
je vais te dire toi tu tu serais pas en
mettre combien non alors à mon avis le
vrai prix franchement parce que tennis
piscine énorme terrain domaine privé
d'ailleurs il charge il faut rappeler
les charges immense mais c'est énorme
les charges entre le gardiennage il
avait il a une maison de gardien aussi
comment tu sais pourquoi vous êtes allé
mais vous êtes cité parmi les acquéreurs
possibles
pour faire monter le prix donc si tu es
où exactement
c'est malin de faire ça pour la
négociation
comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le vrai prix mon avis c'est l'endroit
exceptionnel c'est 8 millions maximum
mais moi je crois qu'elle peut être
négociable à
680000 € demain tout de suite c'est
virement tout de suite vous voulez pas
faire une offre pour notre coloc
ça peut être rigolo il y a six chambres
et ouais vous emmerdez pas la maison
TPMP
[Musique]
mais non si on veut continuer l'émission
Tout le monde va venir le week-end toi
et là il y a que 6 chambres 8 sans qu'il
va dire une connerie
alors oui non mais ce qui est
intéressant dans ce domaine c'est que
également il y a Monsieur Jacques
Séguéla le grand publicitaire et c'est
là que ce serait rencontré Nicolas
Sarkozy avec d'accord
donc la maison est-ce que tu penses
qu'elle va se vendre et la maison non
mais la maison je crois que même si on
est fan de Johnny comme je le suis et
comme tant d'autres leçons et vous aussi
là où il est mort il a souffert il a
beaucoup souffert la fin tout ça moi
c'est un truc que j'achèterai jamais de
ma vie de toute façon je n'ai pas les
moyens mais je pense pas ils vont avoir
beaucoup de mal parce que même au-delà
du mythe Johnny il faut quand même
sortir beaucoup d'argent et il y a une
vraie tristesse dans cette maison quand
même il y a le savez les maisons ce sont
des actions elle va être contente
[Rires]
bien assis d'ailleurs si je vais vous
dire je vais être extrêmement honnête
avec vous et avec elle quand je l'ai vu
au restaurant tu sais qu'on est fâché
depuis 5 ans suite dans les bras non non
j'étais avec des gens de Canal Plus
d'ailleurs et je disais aux personnes de
Canal+ je dis soit elle vomit en me
voyant soit elle me gifle soit
s'évanouit alors ça les a amusé de me
voir arriver je suis allé vers elle
c'est moi je suis allé vers elle j'ai
dit Laetitia c'est quand même dommage
tout ce qui nous arrive alors elle était
très touchée au bord des larges très
mignonne alors franchement moi je
t'aurais pété la gueule
que oui puis là je m'étais dit bon
j'avais une chemise blanche avec le sang
c'est pas grave
elle était très mignonne ça me touchait
énormément
ta démarche tu m'as fait beaucoup de mal
tu marchais comment je lui dis mais
évidemment j'ai fait du mal mais moi
c'était juste une question des résultats
je te cache pas que Johnny c'est pour
lui qu'il écrit j'oublierai ton nom hein
uniquement pour les questions d'héritage
les enfants oui oui on s'est parlé
écoute en tout cas elle a dit très
touchée essaie de ne pas vendre ma
maison
je dois parler de la maison
mais elle était mignonne elle était à
plus rien voilà
je t'embrasse Laetitia tu le sais donc
ça y est c'est reparti là mais rien
n'est reparti d'abord est à Los Angeles
et puis voilà mais en tout cas je
souhaite qu'elle vende sa maison le plus
cher parce qu'elle doit encore beaucoup
d'impôts alors justement alors justement
un point là-dessus pour ceux qui nous
rejoignent à 19h54 tu sais alors c'est
quoi le pluriel grosse marge de
négociation sur la maison parce que
c'est assez urgent pour elle il y a 30
millions donc de passifs de dettes
fiscales que Johnny avait il y avait une
première échéance qui a été reportée
jusqu'au 15 décembre puis fin décembre
elle a pu payer une partie mais c'est
avec la vente de cette maison qu'elle
compte combler cette large dette fiscale
donc elle va préférer pour baisser le
prix parce que sinon elle est
complètement coincée le reste de
l'argent est dans un trust américain
qu'elle ne peut pas saisir même elle
donc elle a vraiment besoin de cette
liquidité pour éponger la dette fiscale
de 30 millions mais ça suffira pas il y
a déjà une partie qui a été payée ce
sera une autre grosse partie et le fisc
le fils qu'en fait ne l'a harcèle pas au
jour le jour parce qu'il y a cette
maison d'accord donc à un moment le fils
c'est très bien il discute beaucoup il y
a pas du tout et donc
si on lui donne
son fer avec Monsieur Raynaud est un
copain de tapis 9 millions et les
proposer et prenez l'histoire non vous
connaissez l'histoire sache-le c'est non
vous êtes intéressé vous serez ou pas
à mon avis réellement
peut pas y aller tous les week-ends
sa dette assez rapidement parce que ça
lui coûte cher tous les mois il y a des
intérêts il y a tout ça et c'est vrai
que il faut qu'elle vende très vite la
maison effectivement
ah ben oui là ça y est tout est soldé
les histoires avec tous les mois celles
qui payent des charges là ah mais c'est
qui paye forcément là les charges c'est
quoi les responsable de tout maintenant
par exemple
[Musique]
noter les spectateurs parce que là le
fils il aura laissé jusqu'à quand ah ben
c'était 15 décembre l'échéance voilà et
maintenant il y a plus d'ultimatum
puisque le fisc c'est que infini ils
peuvent saisir la maison et leur vendre
aux enchères Cyril
au bout d'un moment c'est ça vous ne
vendez pas on saisit et on va la mettre
aux enchères
le pire parce que donc du coup elle va
être obligée de descendre s'il y a pas
d'acheteur éponger la tête du fils ça
c'est sûr jusqu'à combien parce qu'à un
moment à mon avis sur cette maison c'est
ou pas non a priori non non donc tout
l'argent il y a pas de crédit forcément
non mais tout l'argent va lui revenir
qu'elle va donner office direct
c'est juste aussi pour s'en débarrasser
parce que 20000 euros
d'ailleurs je sais que j'allais et il va
avec ses enfants sa famille et tout ça
ils y vont souvent ouais mais bon quand
même comment tu fais comment tu t'en
sors ah non c'est impossible
les boulangers c'est le truc qui met le
plus
mais c'est vrai que
Aurélie quand tu dévisses
non mais mine de rien en vrai là c'est
une dette énorme ça comment tu fais pour
ton débarrasser ça c'est un truc ça
c'est un boulet
comment tu fais ça te coûte de l'argent
il faut vraiment l'idée première c'est
sans débarrasser c'est la vendre mais
évidemment ça lui fait la peine d'abord
financièrement de la vendre de la brader
j'envoie que les autres elle a donné
l'exclusivité à une seule agence ou elle
a donné à plein d'agences elle a changé
d'agence elle a changé la lance et ils
viennent
après ce qu'elle laisse les choses
dedans ou pas elle laisse des choses
qui sont pris ils ont pris l'essentiel
l'essentiel des costumes vraiment très
important
qui est en expo en Belgique mais il y en
a encore je crois dans la maison et qui
peuvent laisser voilà si les personnes
sont intéressées voilà c'est avoir c'est
en plus voilà c'est la maison de Johnny
vous est-ce que vous ça vous gênerait si
vous aviez les moyens je le pose la
question téléspectateurs aussi de
racheter la maison de imaginons on est
dans un rêve vous avez les moyens de
l'acheter est-ce que vous achèteriez
bien moi du tout
au contraire c'est un kiffe et je pense
qu'il joue sur ça bien sûr
toi tu aimes le Narc mais quoi toi tu
aimes la Fame c'est mort
tu pourrais l'acheter tu pourrais
c'est-à-dire non mais
essentiellement tu pourrais l'acheter
quoi bien sûr non mais je trouve que
c'est et je pense qu'il joue sur ça pour
valoriser la maison c'est un musée le
truc c'est quand même c'est quand même
mythique toi tu serais intéressé cette
période de dire voilà j'ai racheté la
maison de Johnny parce que c'est une
belle maison aussi mais je trouve le
fait que la maison est une histoire
c'est top j'aime bien oui mais cette
histoire elle est triste
[Musique]
il y a des gens qui sont morts
non mais je trouve qu'il y a un esprit
dans cette maison et ça se voit à
travers les pièces et même ce qu'elle
représente donc si j'avais les moyens
moi ce sera extraordinaire j'aurais
jamais mais moi je vois plus plutôt des
Américains très très riches qui vont
l'acheter qui vont pas trop savoir qui
est Denis ils vont tout refaire à leur
manière et en fait ils vont effacer le
côté musée
t'aurais pas quelque chose en toi de
Tennessee
de musée et qu'on puisse aller visiter
pour les fans de Johnny et tout Claude
François ça cartonne son moulin depuis
40 ans ça continue d'électricité
aujourd'hui
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]